إنه وقت غير مسبوق مليء
بالتوتر وعدم اليقين ، وتقول
الرعاية الصحية للأطفال في أتلانتا ، أكثر من أي وقت مضى ،
إن الآباء بحاجة إلى تخصيص وقت
لأنفسهم للاعتراف بمشاعرك
والسماح لنفسك بالشعور بأنها لا
تقلل من هذه المشاعر ، وتجنب
مقارنة شعورك بما يشعر به الآخرون.
تمارس جميع العادات الصحية المختلفة
مع اتباع نظام غذائي وممارسة الرياضة روتينًا
يمكن أن يخلق القدرة على التنبؤ ويوفر
إحساسًا بالراحة والأمان ، امنح
نفسك استراحة تفعل أفضل ما لديك من
حدود واضحة لا تنغمس
في العمل على مدار الساعة طوال أيام الأسبوع  حدود حتى
لا تتعرض للإرهاق ، ركز على ما
يمكنك التحكم فيه حتى لا
تتدهور أفكارك وتصبح غامرة ، خذ خمسة افعل
شيئًا لنفسك فقط
لأنك تخصص وقتًا للضحك والفرح.
FaceTime صديق
لا يعني الابتعاد الاجتماعي  العزلة الاجتماعية
وأخيراً ممارسة الامتنان يمكن أن
تساعدك على التركيز على ما لديك بدلاً من
ما لا تفعله في الدقيقة الصحية اليوم ،
أنا ماندي جايزر
جون يو  أنت تعلم أنك تكتب أن هذا الفيروس من
المحتمل أن يستمر في الانتشار لمدة ثمانية عشر
شهرًا إلى عامين ، والتنبؤ
الذي توقعته كلاكما كان حتى
ستين إلى سبعين بالمائة من
السكان في جميع أنحاء العالم ، وهو ما أعلم أن
مارك قاله سابقًا في هذا البرنامج هو
نوع من  حول كيفية تعريفه لمناعة القطيع التي
حذرت من أن هذا قد يشمل
موجة ثانية كبيرة من عدوى فيروس كورونا
في الخريف والشتاء ، لذا فإن
السؤال لك يا جون عندما تنظر إلى
هذه الأرقام هو أنه يمكن أن يكون بهذه الطريقة
أكبر مما نراه الآن
قد تكون تعرف أن ما رأيناه حتى
الآن قد تم التحكم فيه ، وما لم يكن الأمر كذلك
بشكل كبير من خلال الإجراءات التي اتخذناها
إذا تم إطلاق هذه الإجراءات وتوقف الأشخاص
عن الاهتمام
بالمسافة الاجتماعية التي تحتاجها حتى لو
أنهينا الإغلاق ، فلا يزال لديك  لمواصلة
التباعد الاجتماعي وتدابير الصحة العامة الأخرى ،
فقد يصبح
الأمر أسوأ بكثير مما رأيناه
حتى الآن ، وهو تحذير شديد الواقعية
أعني وضع علامة على الفيروس
كان ينتشر على الأقل منذ حوالي خمسة
أشهر وما نفهمه حتى الآن
وفقًا للأرقام الرسمية
، فقد أصيب أقل من 1٪ من سكان العالم
بالعدوى الآن من الواضح أن هذا الرقم
سيكون أعلى بكثير من ذلك ولكنه
لا يزال منخفضًا جدًا  كنسبة
مئوية من سكان العالم ، لذا فإن
الوصول إلى 67 إلى 70 في المائة في غضون عامين
يعني فقط تسارعًا هائلاً
في مرحلة ما من علامة النمذجة الخاصة بك ،
حسنًا ، أعتقد أنه بالطبع
لا يمكنك الحصول على من خمسة في المائة في القليل
من الأشهر إلى 70 في المائة بدون
الكثير من الحالات أكثر مما لدينا
حتى الآن ، وهذا يعني موجة أكبر
إذا أبقيناها تحت
السيطرة بإجراءات تحكم مكثفة حقًا ، فقد لا
نصل إلى 50 أو 70 في المائة بحلول ذلك الوقت ولكن
بعد ذلك ، سنظل بحاجة
إلى لقاح أو أن السكان
لا يزالون عرضة للإصابة ،
لذلك لا يزال هناك الكثير مما لا نعرفه
عن هذا الفيروس ، يواصل الباحثون حول
العالم دراسته على أمل
فهم كيفية spr  يؤثر على البشر
وما إذا كان بإمكاننا تطوير مناعة ،
فإليك ما نعرفه أن الفيروس
يبدو أنه يقتل الرجال بمعدل أعلى
بكثير من النساء على الأقل وفقًا
لبعض البيانات المحدودة التي نحصل عليها
من عدد قليل من البلدان ولكن
الباحثين  هنا في الولايات المتحدة
ويحاولون معرفة ما إذا كان هناك بالفعل
بعض الحقيقة في ذلك ، لذا فهم يجرون
دراسة لتحديد ما إذا كان هرمون الاستروجين ، وهو
هرمون أنثوي ، يمكن أن يقلل من
شدة الأعراض لدى الرجال أو انضممنا إليها الآن
د.  شارون أوكمان عميد مشارك
للأبحاث في كلية
الطب المتجددة في جامعة ستوني بروك
وأيضًا من نفس الجامعة د.
أنطونيوس كاباروس أستاذ الجراحة
شكرا جزيلا لكلا منكما
لأنني أريد أن أتحدث عن هذه
الدراسة الرائعة د.  لقد
فهمت أن هذه كانت فكرتك التي تفكر
بها خارج الصندوق ، لقد نظرت إلى الفجوات بين الجنسين
في بيانات الوفاة على وجه الخصوص
وكان لديك فكرة تخبرنا عنها ،
نعم كانت ملاحظة سريرية بسيطة جدًا
حيث ذكرت الفرق بين الجنسين
وشدتها
المرض الذي يحدث بين الرجال
والنساء ، حيث بدأت بالفعل في
إثارة كل شيء وكنت تعتقد
جيدًا أنه كان السبب الأساسي وراء السؤال
هو لماذا تعرف كما ذكرت حوالي
80 ٪ عندما تنظر إلى خطر
الحاجة إلى التنبيب أو الوفاة أو
الوفاة  حوالي 80٪ من الذكور مقابل 20٪ أو
15٪ من الإناث ، فلماذا هذا
الاختلاف وهذا دفعني لمحاولة أن أرى في
الأدبيات ما الذي نعرفه
وعندما تنظر إلى سلسلة
الفيروسات التاجية التي كانوا مسؤولين
عنها  Co ولكنه يختلف
قليلاً عما هو عليه بالنسبة للعدوى السابقة الأخرى
مثل المصدر
وقد لوحظ هذا الاختلاف بين الجنسين أيضًا في السارس الآن
عندما نظرت في الأدبيات التي
رأيتها كانت  في الدراسات التي أجريت على الحيوانات ، أظهرت
أنه في إناث الفئران كان لها أيضًا
تأثير وقائي وعندما كان هناك
كتلة من هرمون الاستروجين في تلك الفئران الأنثوية ،
فقد اختفى التأثير الوقائي ، لذلك كان
مصير إناث الفئران
مشابهًا للذكور ، لذا
الملاحظة التي ذكرتها
سابقًا بالإضافة إلى هذا المسرح
الذي وجدت
أن السؤال هو هل يمكن أن
تعطي إدارة الإستروجين تأثيرًا وقائيًا
للذكور أو الفرسان المعارضين للنساء
في هذه المسألة
لمنع تقدم الرئة لتتطلب التنبيب أمرًا
رائعًا حتى تفهم
أنك  لقد سجل المريض الأول الذي
وضع الرجال على أقدام إيستريدج مع
هذا الهرمون الأنثوي د.
Nachmann وأخبرنا عما تفعله بالفعل ،
فهذه الدراسة عبارة عن دراسة عشوائية
لأننا لا نعرف ما إذا
كانت ستنجح في الواقع ، لذا فإن ما نقوم به هو اختيار
عشوائي للمرضى الذين تزيد
أعمارهم عن 18 عامًا أو النساء فوق سن 55  من حيث
أنهم في فترة ما بعد انقطاع الطمث عن طريق الصدفة
إما الحصول على لصقة الاستروجين لمدة
سبعة أيام أو العلاج الوهمي ولمعرفة كيف
يفعلون ذلك إذا كانوا أقل
دخولًا إلى المستشفى بسبب حالات دخول أقل
إلى وحدة العناية المركزة وفي الواقع عدد أقل من
التنبيب ، لذلك مع وثيقة طبيبك
فقط  للالتزام بهذا ، أعني
كيف تعتقد أن هرمون الاستروجين يغير استجابة الجسم
المناعية لفيروس كورونا ، أعني
ما الذي تبحث عنه هنا ، ما
الذي تأمل أن يفعله بجسد الرجل الذي
يبدو أنه يفعله بالفعل
بجسد أنثوي ، لذلك نأمل  أنه في
الواقع سيساعد استجابتهن المناعية عندما
يرون الفيروس ، فإن هذه الكمية من
التصحيح لمدة سبعة أيام يتم وضعها أولاً مرة واحدة فقط
لن يكون لها أي تأثير أنثوي
على الرجال الذين يحصلون عليها ، وقد
تساعد النساء اللائي تزيد أعمارهن عن 55 عامًا على  يكون ثعبان البحر
أفضل قليلاً عندما يكونون في مرحلة ما بعد انقطاع الطمث ،
لكن لن يكون له أي تأثير سلبي على تأنيث
هؤلاء المرضى ،
ونأمل أن يساعد ذلك في حمايتهم من
الفيروس ، فنحن فقط نسجل الأشخاص الذين
لا تظهر عليهم أعراض الفيروس والذين
خضعوا لاختبار كوفات إيجابي لذلك نحن
يفكرون في أن كل من هم في
الدراسة سيحصلون بالفعل على
kovat ، لذلك نأمل أن
تحميهم من التقدم من مرض
السعال الثقيل.
سعال
لشخص يستخدم دمية يملأ فمه
بمزيج من الجلسرين والماء ثم
بمضخة تقلع اللهاية
ثم انتظر لترى إلى أي مدى
تنتقل القطرات تملأ الهواء المرئي
بضوء الليزر الأخضر الذي يحاكي ما
يحدث عندما  ضعيفًا يولد
جزيئات بترتيب من 10 إلى 20
ميكرون وهو قريب تقريبًا
من أصغر أحجام القطرات عندما
نسميها لاحظ كيف تكون سريعة  kly ،
قطيرات الجهاز التنفسي المحاكية المنتشرة 1 ،
قطعت القطرات المطرودة مسافة
3 أقدام على الفور تقريبًا في غضون 5
ثوانٍ ، كانت القطرات على ارتفاع 6 أقدام ثم
9 أقدام في حوالي 10 ثوانٍ فقط ، تذكر أن
9 أقدام هي 3 أقدام خارج
إرشادات التباعد الاجتماعي الموصى بها والتي
وصلت بالفعل تقريبًا  9 أقدام الآن ، لا
يزال ضباب القطرات في الهواء ،
لكنه استمر في التحرك للأمام
لمدة 30 إلى 40 ثانية أخرى لتطفو
3 أقدام أخرى ، نعم قال 12 قدمًا
مرارًا وتكرارًا ،
فجر المحاكاة علامة 6 أقدام غالبًا ما يضاعف
ذلك  المسافة يقول البروفيسور إن
القطرات تصبح أقل كثافة
كلما ابتعدت عن السفر لكنها ما زالت معلقة في
الهواء مع القدرة على تحمل
المرض ومشاهدة هذا حتى عندما نضع
قناعًا بسيطًا على الجسيمات الوهمية التي
لا تزال مشتتة من جوانب
القناع على الرغم من  لم يسافروا لمسافات
طويلة بالتأكيد إذا كنت لا ترتدي قناعًا من
المفترض أن تضعه في
كوعك ولكن إذا كنت نعش في يدك  s هو
ما يحدث لنطفئ الأنوار
، سأضع يدي على فم
هذه الدمية وأحاكي السعال ، يمكنك
رؤية القطرات تتناثر في جميع
الاتجاهات ، وقد لا يسافرون إلى مسافة بعيدة ربما حوالي 3
أقدام أو نحو ذلك لكنهم يرشون  في كل مكان
ويمكنهم البقاء في الهواء ربما لمدة
ثلاث دقائق من شدة القهوة ،
لذلك اختبرنا السعال اللطيف حتى
السعال الخفيف لم يذهب بعيدًا على
الإطلاق حوالي ثلاثة أقدام ولكن يبقى السؤال ما
مدى قربك
تعتقد استنادًا إلى ما رأيته في
مختبرك الخاص أن ستة أقدام كافية
للتباعد الاجتماعي ستة أقدام هو الحد الأدنى
للمسافة التي يجب عليك الاحتفاظ بها ، ويبدو
أن المزيد من الأفضل هو الأفضل